and finally new rule for the next two
years every time a politician says
middle-class economics we all get to
take a drink oh yes even the Republicans
are jumping on the bandwagon with
middle-class economics it's the new
[ __ ] and it's what's for dinner and
I say [ __ ] because the middle income
in America is fifty one thousand dollars
in the average family that makes that
even with no car payments no cable TV no
vacation and no money even for a pet coz
they had to eat it you are still $50 in
the red at the end of every month and up
until like Thursday the Republican
answer to that was always just to say
well that's the new normal like that's
an explanation try that one when your
wife comes home early and finds you
screwing the babysitter what the hell's
going on here it's the new normal
now I know what you're thinking but Bill
isn't it a good thing the Republicans
are finally paying attention to our
vanishing middle class like this lady
with the same people and see policies it
got a since the status quo another Latin
word status quo and it stands for man
the middle class every day Americans are
really getting taken for a ride now this
raises a troubling question which is if
Sarah Palin suffers a stroke how will we
know
now
I don't know from that if Sarah Palin is
for or against helping the middle class
and there's no way to know but there's a
lot of that kind of talk going around
Jeb Bush recently said while the last
eight years have been pretty good ones
for top earners they've been a lost
decade for the rest of America and Mitt
Romney the man with four mansions in a
car elevator I said under President
Obama the rich have gotten richer and
the income inequality has gotten worse
yeah those damn Democrats always
fighting the Republican Party's efforts
to stick up with a little guy yeah Wow
there is no shame in the Republican game
this is the party that used to like to
say a rising tide lifts all boats which
is easy to say when you're on the yacht
so what's happening is the Democrats are
proposing to nibble around the edges of
our middle-class problem and the
Republicans are pretending to care while
they go back to servicing eight rich
[ __ ] who own coal mines and no one
is telling the truth which is that the
large thriving middle class that America
used to have didn't just appear out of
the blue it was created using an
economic tool called socialism oh I know
we never use that term here in buzzword
nation but that is exactly what our
government did after World War two it
taxed the rich up to ninety percent and
massively redistributed that money
through the GI Bill so that more than
half the population benefited from free
college free job training cheap
mortgages and much much more
yes for a brief shining moment we were
Finland
now we can debate whether that's a good
thing or a bad thing to go back to but
what is beyond debate is that that is
what happened the 50s and 60s are the
era of socialism in America and that is
when a family needed only one brint
breadwinner and a house cost only two
years salary it was when a man could
afford college for his kids and dinner
at a chop house with the missus followed
by missionary sex in a paneled rec room
on a plastic covered sofa that wipes
clean because here's the reality a
middle-class is actually not the normal
byproduct of the capitalism ask any
historian a middle class is actually a
fluke in history like in the 14th
century middle class was created in
Europe when during the Black Plague 1/3
of the population died resulting in a
labor shortage and increased bargaining
power for workers so that's one way to
create a middle class but it is kind of
hard to see it on a campaign book